[Music]
thank you
what your mother never told you you were
royalty the women in our family have the
mighty power to turn into giant Kraken
what now Ruby you're a princess
[Music]
I am having a panic attack
okay Ruby have a completely totally
ordinary day you got that
[Music]
I feel like a freak ow I just want to be
Ruby Gilman normal teenager oh boo
where's the fun in that you have powers
beyond your imagination
you are the protector of all the oceans
creatures it's up to you to stop the
evil mermaids but people love mermaids
of course they do people are stupid
show me how to use my power are you
ready
let's see what you're capable of body
armor
almost
it's time to go big
uh we're still on for our tutoring
session later right oh
anything from my algae do what no I mean
bro
algebra like you're my brother you're my
math brother
I think I like the first one better
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you
foreign